Ein Zauberer und eine Lampe,
die mehr kann als leuchten.
An dieser Zaubernummer hat Patrick
Lehnen gut(e) vier Jahre lang gearbeitet -
an Bühnenbild, Musik
und Dramaturgie.
Dass sie die Leute wirklich berührt
und etwas auslöst in einem.
Dass man halt nicht nur guckt und denkt:
Ach, das war ja verblüffende Zauberei,
sondern dass es einen wirklich berührt
und bewegt und wahre Emotionen schafft.
Und das ist ihm gelungen,
denn die freche Zauberlampe
schließt man sofort ins Herz.
Wenn Patrick Lehnen nicht
auf der Bühne steht,
arbeitet der 34-jährige Kölner haupt-
beruflich als Programmierer.
Seine Zauberlampe hat er selbst
gebaut und verkabelt.
Ein mühseliger Akt.
Das (das) ist ein Schaltplan, so ist
die Verkabelung quasi intern.
Ja, ganz schön kompliziert.
Ich hab' ja drei Jahre an dieser
Nummer gebastelt,
bis ich sie dann das erste Mal
zeigen konnte und dann
saß ich da in dem Theater und ja, spielte
diese Nummer und wusste einfach gar nicht:
Wie kommt das jetzt an?
Also mögen die Leute das oder nicht? Ist
das nur in meinem Kopf toll oder nicht? Und
zum Schluss gab’s dann 'ne Standing Ovation
und dann wusste ich: Ja, toll, klappt. Geht!
Das Jonglieren hat ihm geholfen,
zaubern zu lernen,
denn auch dabei geht es in erster
Linie um Fingerfertigkeit.
Vor elf Jahren sah er Kartenkunststücke
im Internet und begann sie nachzumachen -
bis er alle Griffe drauf hatte.
Dann war irgendwie der Funke
übergesprungen und ich hab'
versucht, alles zu lernen, was ich
irgendwie finden konnte an Kartentricks.
(Und) Aber nicht so wirklich, nicht so
in der Intention,
das vorzuführen, sondern
mehr so für mich,
so einfach so als Challenge
so ‘n bisschen rumspielen.
Auf der Suche nach neuen Kartentricks
besuchte er Zauberwarenhändler
und lernte dabei andere Magier und
weitere Zauberkunststücke kennen.
Nimmst Du auch Quittungen?
Nein, nur Bares ist Wahres.
Ah, ok. Kein Problem. Dann machen
wir es einfach bar. Wie immer …
Ja, das war die erste Anlaufstelle, wie
ich so die Kollegen kennengelernt habe
und erst vom „Magischen Zirkel“
erfahren habe.
Ja, und so bekam ich halt die Gelegen-
heit, da auch Mitglied zu werden.
Inzwischen bin ich ja sogar in Bonn im
Vorstand dabei und ja, mag das sehr gerne.
Derzeit organisiert er mit anderen
Mitgliedern des „Magischen Zirkels“
die Bonner Zauberwochen. Zu sehen sind
die besten Zauberkünstler des Landes
aus ganz unterschiedlichen Sparten,
wie der Bayer Samuel Goldmann
aus dem Bereich der Manipulation.
An meiner Manipulationsnummer
hab‘ ich
so in der Form jetzt fast
fünf Jahre gearbeitet.
Und es ist für ‘ne normale Manipulations-
nummer auch durchaus normal,
weil es einfach Jahre dauert, bis man
überhaupt die Basics erlernt hat.
Also die Griffe, zum Beispiel hier so was:
ein ganz typischer Griff für Manipulatoren.
Großillusionen hingegen sind nur im Team
zu bewältigen und benötigen viel Platz.
Mit ihren selbst gebauten Zaubermaschinen
sind „Flic-Flac Modern Magic“
aus Landau in der Pfalz schon zweimal
Deutscher Meister geworden.
Bei den Großillusionen ist
Timing sehr wichtig.
Dass alles genau auf die Musik passt,
dass jeder weiß, wann er was zu tun hat.
Also Timing ist da das
Wichtigste von allem.
Und das ist sehr schwierig,
das muss man lange üben.
Immer wieder, immer wieder
das Gleiche durchführen,
proben, üben, bis es so richtig passt.
Der Klassiker der Großillusion
ist die „zersägte Jungfrau“ -
in immer neuen Variationen.
Es gibt so viele unfassbar
gute Zaubernummern,
und die haben jetzt nicht das Element,
was (was) sie besonders macht.
Immer irgendwie was Spezielles:
Manchmal ist es der Charakter,
der unfassbar faszinierend ist, dass
man die ganze Zeit zuschauen möchte.
Manchmal ist es ein spezieller Effekt,
der so verblüffend ist,
dass man es immer wieder gucken
möchte oder manchmal
ist einfach die Story so mitreißend.
Wie bei seiner Zauberlampe.
Mit ihr hat Patrick Lehnen eine ganz
eigene Form magischer Poesie erschaffen.
Ein Highlight in der geheimnisvollen
Welt der Magie.